I always thought there must be another
way of things other than just doing a 9
to-5 Rat Race and kind of looked into
right anybody who's had success what do
they do and regardless of what
industrial sector are in they always had
a percentage of their wealth in property
how long did it take you to get your
first deal so it was quite a while once
we've got on that first one that's when
we went ah right it's like a light bulb
moment for a month and a half after that
we got our second one am I going to come
up with excuses as to why this doesn't
work and why it's too good to be true or
am I going to just actually do it make
some money and join the winning team
you've got to go and get the knowledge
and training you can't go in this stuff
blind I just think it you're doomed for
fail if you
do so Craig welcome to winners on a
Wednesday thank you thank you for having
me Sam so you've got a little bit of a
different story because you were made
redundant in May this year I was yeah
how did you feel when you were told you
were losing your job yeah it was scary
obviously we've having two kids as well
you know there is a commitment there
yeah um but I really managed to really
focus on my why which at the time was
around time and being time constraint so
it allowed me to really focus and and
dig down into property right which so
it's a blessing in disguise yeah 100%
And you were working before doing
customer service yes yeah I was a
customer service manager in it been in
that in that industry for about eight or
nine years yeah um definitely was time
to to make a change and uh yeah here we
are now today what you think is more
risky having a job or having a business
I would definitely say having a job
being from the it sector at the moment
there's a real risk there with loads of
redundancies across the board I mean
you're looking at some of the big
companies out there like the huge
companies um I know from friends that
work with women as well there's just job
Cuts being made left right and Center
yeah I'm seeing it all the time now I
mean back in the day it was play it safe
have a job a job for life I don't think
that exists anymore and with with things
like AI as a businessman AI excites me
because I think how can I improve my
business yeah but as an employee I I can
mean oh actually we've automated it's
your job mate you know cut you you're
redundant now so you came um I think you
came to a discovery day um to my to my
house um and that was I don't know how
long ago it was now a year yeah about
yeah about 11 yeah 11 12 months ago yeah
interesting story actually so I came
along sat there there was quite a few
successful people and uh I was thought
what am I doing here I'm in the complete
wrong place this is not for me met a guy
called Tony who I didn't know who he was
at the time was having a chat and uh I
kind of said to him like I I think I'm
in the wrong place here he said what
what did you do for living I said I'm a
customer success manager in it he said
no you're in the exact right place
you're good with numbers and uh fast
forward about two hours later he stood
up and I found out he was your Mentor
yeah made millions of pounds in property
Millions he's done over 100 million yeah
so uh no it was it was fun day why did
you feel you were in the wrong place at
the first was it because everyone was
like so successful yeah so obviously I
started I had no knowledge or background
in property at all at that time um and I
was just seeing all these people having
successes and you know they were saying
oh we've got 30 Apartments 50 apartments
and I just thought I'm in the wrong room
I'm in the wrong with the wrong crowd of
people and uh yeah obviously I was a bit
skeptical as well like I'd heard you say
how you can like you know manage and
take on property without any of your
money and I was a bit like hm that's a
that's an interesting one I want to go
along I want to find out a bit more
about this yeah and I know as well your
family were pretty skeptical right yeah
100% at the very beginning obviously I
come along I was really interested in it
um protecting with my wife Becker on it
she's the brains beyond the operation I
brought her along to the pound course
and we just didn't look back that's you
know what that's the best thing to do to
get your to get your family on board is
to just say look pay a pound come down
to the property investus crash course
and see for yourself it was the best
thing that sh did probably coming along
and now you've had the support of of
Becca who I know has been massively
influential and you you've you've grown
the business together which is so much
more fun than than trying to grow a
business and your wife's just there in
the background like not sure sure you
know having somebody that's on board and
gets it yeah you know really makes sense
so did you do the training before or
after you were made redundant so some of
it I had done before I think like I said
it was my why but it was also probably
one of my biggest challenges was time
yeah um I had real big time constraints
around my job I was working like 13 14
hour days so I was just trying to fit in
any little bit in any Nock or cranny
that I had and it' normally be half hour
or an hour in the evening what I just
found is is when the redundancy come
along it really allow me to accelerate
and go through all of the trains
properly and really deep dive and hit
after being made redundant how long did
it take you to become financially
independent so for me I suppose across
the borders what weird classes on
average wage yeah which maybe about two
grand yeah I was on probably a
significant wage at the time so I was on
about 85k a year sure that was probably
one of the biggest worries and concerns
I had but I would say probably within
from May I would say from July August we
really started seeing the success come
and that's where I could say you know
what I'm out the nin to-5 rap race and
we can really drive this forward that's
pretty good though you know just just
two or three months to be a point where
you've replaced the average salary maybe
not your current salary but the average
salary what strategy did you use to
become financially fore we first focused
on rent to rents you know we've seen a
lot of success from that and that's
something that we're going to continue
to build out um we then Focus probably
I'd say within the last two months
around the deal selling side and deal
sourcing um and we have started to see
some good success from that as well
whether that be us um Source it and sell
it directly to an investor or we
co-source and work work with another
deal sourcer to Sure align the investor
and the deal together what's the
difference between straight deal selling
when you package a deal find an investor
sell the deal and then code deal
sourcing like what what's the difference
between the two so obviously with a
direct um deal Source straight to
investor you know you're find the deal
for them you'll make sure it fits their
requirements you'll package it all
together you'll give them a clear
overview of you know what the average
nightly rate will be and occupancy and
what they can expect as a average profit
per month with the uh co- sourcing side
it may be for instance I found a
specific deal and another sourc has got
a specific investor that it fits their
requirements yeah we would then come
together and then package that together
and obviously split the fees makes sense
so you're basically tapping into their
list yeah they're selling it they're
dealing with the investors and all that
but you're finding the deal and then you
you're splitting the profits see I
personally believe Craig I believe that
every property investor or even aspiring
property investor should be a deal
sourcer because when you're a property
investor you're out looking at deals all
the time for yourself anyway you're
looking at rent to rents you're looking
at you know brrs you're look at holiday
lets you're looking at properties you
can't take on everything no no
definitely because you just haven't
physically got the resources or or or
the capacity to take every deal on for
yourself so you're either going to see
decent deals but don't quite work for
you because they're outside of your
patch or whatever whatever and just
flush it down the drone or find deals
for yourself and then when you come
across other Deals they oh that's good
but I can't quite take it on sell it or
pass it to someone else to sell and
split the fee yeah and that's exactly
what happened to us really so we had
just uh joint ventured on our second sa
um and everything was just taking the
initial you know stag in and stuff like
that and um a deal had come up to us
which by figures and we were really
interested in doing it but TimeWise like
you've just said it just wouldn't have
wouldn't have made a match so we
actually decided to to s that on and
it's a win-win for everyone makes sense
what's your where do you live and what's
your patch for your properties that
you're doing so we live in South
Buckingham share and our patch where we
have our rent to rent sessay at the
moment is in Harford share um in Watford
area um we're also like with agents and
landlords we're working with is in the
general London London area as well so
how long did it take you to get your
first deal from when you you know went
on the academy and were looking for
deals how how many months or how many
weeks was it so it was quite a while I
think our initial struggles were at the
beginning in trying to get that and and
trying to work with agents and landlords
um and we actually got support and and
worked with the twins on getting our
first deal you awesome on the academy sh
out G Mitch they are they're amazing you
know they they really do help all the
academy members they're they're
fantastic and yeah I think probably
about once we've got our foot like over
the line on that first one that's when
we went ah right it's like a light bulb
moment this how it works and it kind of
spiraled and I'd say probably a month a
month and a half after that we got our
second one do you reckon that your first
deal is your hardest 100% yeah I think
so and I think even with selling deals I
speak to a lot of investors who are
super established investors that you
know even some of them are you know
multi-millionaires and they're like I'm
going to try and do a bit of deal
selling because you know why not and
they're struggling but then when you get
your first deal sold it's like something
clicks and it's like okay that's how it
works and you just can do it again and
again and again and again yeah which has
been your favorite course and you've
done a lot of training programs with
with myself um what do you think's been
the best one so it's probably I would
say the brrr so refinance um is that
next for you is that it is yes that's
definitely something we want to get into
and probably going back to before he can
join the academy um in my mind that that
is the kind of the Avenue we wanted to
go down yeah um it's just full of just
so much content and each step is broken
down that even though I haven't got one
today by all of the training I've done
I'd feel quite confident in going going
ahead with one straight away so yeah and
that's the key confidence comes from
knowledge so when you know when you know
what you're doing and we try our best on
the trainers to not just teach but get
you on the phones and get people
actually speaking and doing things
because that's the real way to learn
isn't it is to is to do it yeah 100%
yeah you can take all of the knowledge
and then you know don't do anything with
it it's basically useless so talk to me
about Power Team because presumably
you're not managing the properties
cleaning the properties every time you
get a guest going checking them in
yourself you've got systems in place and
maybe team in place so talk to me about
the members of the team the things that
you can automate and how you managed to
do that I say probably with our power
team the main driving force is our
cleaners um you know they are our eyes
and ears on the ground um they manage
obviously all the turnovers and
everything like that we have a
maintenance man that we can lean on as
well from time to time where if there's
little certain things need to be done
for instance you know if there's a
problem with a tap or something like
that um and then with regards to
automating the business and systems um
we have a channel manager in place as
well um that basically effectively
manages both properties you know we can
see who's checking in when when there's
checkouts when there needs to be a quick
turnover late checkout so it really
allows us to to kind of have a hands off
approach so to speak so yeah which
channel manager do you use uh when use
up listing nice and Which online travel
agencies are you on are you on all of
them like you're on buck.com late rooms
everything so we are yeah and I think
one of our USPS is by been on so many
OTAs um and we see and have had a lot of
success down the like relocators
interesting and stuff like thatum and
they're probably some of the OTAs that
most people wouldn't recognize or be
aware of yeah you know like home and
away stuff like that and we've had quite
a lot of success from them interesting
because everyone that isn't trained
properly we just think oh stick it on
Airbnb and I'll just wait for the
bookings to roll in and of course that
can work if if you're in an area which
is an absolute Bang area yeah that can
work but generally speaking I think you
got to be a bit more proactive and
you've got to think who's my market who
am I actually use just mentioned
relocators cool where where am how can I
be how can I maximize my marketing be as
on many different platforms as possible
tweaking my prices being aware paying
attention I think that that's something
that's missing in the business by people
that aren't properly trained doing it
properly I don't know if you'd agree
with that yeah 100% And I like that from
from the training that we've had you
know you're able to focus on okay
your patch what is going on in your area
what type of people is that going to
bring to that area okay so I know that
that's going to be one of my target
markets how do I get my business to them
how can I showcase them what I've got
and what I do and then obviously from
there you're able to grow and get some
of them longer longer term bookings
how's life changed then now because I
know that you do okay financially and
and you're making a living and you're
full-time in property but like your life
must be quite different now to what it
was like a year ago yeah 100% um I get
to see a lot more the outside which is
fantastic um I also get to pick and
choose when I work kind of thing so
instead of being stuck in that 9 to-5
Rat Race you know behind a desk all day
every day I'm now able to maybe flip it
where I could go oh I'm able to go and
pick up my kids from school today and
maybe spend an hour or so over the park
and then adjust it where I'll work later
in the evenings or certain times in the
day so especially with how it's
systemized as well I also find it it
actually helps me in my personal life
systemize how my day is going to go as
well so that's great that's really cool
and your family were pretty skeptical at
first um obviously your wife was
supportive but what do your family think
now about what it's been fantastic so
when we first got the rent to rents um
they were very very skeptical and you
know was given the message of you know
just be careful and make sure you know
what you're getting into but my father
and my father in-law have been really
supportive you know they've helped us
with staging on some of the
accomodations we've had um we're
actually at the point now where they've
been to one of your pound courses boom
there we go and uh we're speaking about
them potentially becoming investors for
us on our BR project that's awesome
that's awesome it's as I said before
when when you send people to the crash
course you can't argue with the facts
because the thing is people can watch a
quick YouTube video and think oh that
sounds too good to be true or if it was
that good everyone would be doing it or
if you're making so much money in
property why you teaching people and all
these things which are legitimate
questions but when you come down and you
actually come to a property versus Crash
Course pay a pound meet me in person
yeah meet all the different people that
are in property and see the experiences
and the cas studies and have everything
logically broken down as to how it works
and the agencies and the suddenly you
can't argue with it and it's like hang
on a minute am I going to come up of
excuses as to why this doesn't work and
why it's too good to be true or am I
going to just actually do it make some
money and join the winning team and you
know you can't really not I think when
when you come on a crash course it opens
your eyes and it almost ruins you like I
bet you would never ever get a job ever
again now no no I definitely wouldn't
it's a you know a complete lifestyle
change and like you said from from all
of that is complete eye opener I I found
that I end up leaving the pound course
and my wife and was a bit like how did
we not know about this it's certain
things that you think you just never
have heard of in before yeah but so
simple yeah exactly and what have you
got in the pipeline then Craig what's
what's going on now so we've got a lot
coming up in the pipeline at the moment
um so yeah we're due to build out time
frame with one of the landlords we're
working with to take on the remainder of
the block so that would be we've got one
in the moment that'll be four in total
from deal Source inside of things uh
we've got a block coming up in London
which is for eight Apartments um and
we're also speaking with someone which
would be co-sourced with another Academy
member about another apartment block
which is for 74 Apartments oh wow um so
yeah a a lot of things in apartment some
big stuff yeah what made you flip your
strategy from initially when we first
met you were wanting to do buy refurbish
refinance and go down that route to then
flipping your strategy and suddenly
going down deal sourcing rent to rents
and being more of a property
entrepreneur how did that how did that
change and why so I think when I first
looked into it I really didn't have the
understanding of like Fast pound and
then building like generational wealth
yeah um in in my mind it was just right
BR that's the way you know I'll I'll
I'll buy maybe one property two
properties if I can and then over time
you know there'll be that capital
appreciation and you know it'll be a
little Nest EG um from obviously going
on the courses and being part of the
academy you know I've understood that
the the entrepreneurial side you know
the fast the fast pound that I can earn
obviously with deal sourcing rent to
rents um and then longterm build into
that and building a lot more
generational wealth either with my money
or other people's money and make it a
win-win for everyone around it makes
sense and and and running property as a
business and being a property
entrepreneur is so good because not only
is the money fast and life changing but
also when you're in the business and
you've got properties under control and
you're sourcing properties it's very
easy then to start building your
portfolio because you're out on the road
you're speaking to agents you've got
your team in place so it makes sense
what's been the biggest challenge then
Craig besides being made redundant and
thinking holy moly I'm sure that was a
challenge yeah um but what would you say
has been some of the biggest challenges
and problems that you faced I'd probably
say the main two would be at the
beginning was time although it was my
why um I really struggled at the
beginning to try and dedicate myself as
as much as I wanted to yeah um and
probably at times also asked a bit too
much myself I mean we only have so much
time in a day but um again if you can't
and you're not able to commit you you
need to try and find the nooks and
crannies to be able to fit it in um and
get the education that you need the
other part as well I'd probably say at
the beginning that we struggled with is
the building the brand aspect of it sure
um so like my wife for instance she
found I think we'd only been on the
academy maybe four weeks or six weeks
and we found some really good BR deals
but where we hadn't built the brand or
maybe networked enough we couldn't find
investors that it would have been a good
fit for um and I mean like the returns
were like 25% and stuff like that but I
would say that was a real big challenge
that we had at the beginning yeah not
people not know who you are yeah as
Grant cardo my mentor says um contacts
equals contracts you know you have to
have people you have have to not only
know people but also have people know
you yeah and I think that you've done
that well now people I think it was even
T that reached out to me and was like
you have to get Craig on your on your on
your channel because you you've made a
lot of friends on the academy yeah and I
mean you know one other thing with the
academy like because we're on about the
networking side everyone helps everyone
I mean there's so many guys you know
like teshy Adam Kieran all those the
twins all those guys you know just help
everyone and you really want to see
everyone be pulled up and have success
so it's good how would you say you've
changed as a person over the last year
if you have I would probably say one of
the things that I'm maybe do more and
although I had a big aspect of it from
work but probably what I do more now is
instead of look at looking at things as
okay what's there for me it's more like
how can I add value um and that's you
know when I'm doing deals and maybe
crunching numbers and making sure that
they're really conservative numbers or
if it's just supporting someone like I I
think more of a bigger picture is um how
can I help someone and and from that you
do get a real good feel feel factor from
it I believe that I believe what goes
around comes around I believe in Good
Karma I believe in givers gain
especially on the academy you know
people sometimes people join the academy
and they'll spend the first month just
helping people passing people
opportunities connecting and I'm
thinking they're going to be super
successful because everyone's raving
about them and everyone's everyone's
benefiting from that person and you reap
what you sow so I think that's a that's
a great Outlook how's it affected your
relationship I know you've been working
with Becca um on on the business how's
it affected your relationship are you
guys happier you say or yeah definitely
is it challenging working together like
what's no no no I mean I mean she's the
brains behind the brawn right so I think
in the ground scheme thing it's probably
um made our relationship a lot stronger
in some ways um you know we we have
boundaries where it's like right no work
time like sure phone's off for a bit let
just chill but then I find that time a
bit more special with her as well and
yeah I think like together cuz we're
both pulling in the same direction for
the same thing and obviously um you know
when you're both in jobs you're making
someone else Rich right whereas
obviously when it's your business and
it's for yourselves it's to help like
grow and you guys will benefit from that
so yeah we you're both putting the same
direction it's definitely made us a lot
strong and how old are you kids um so my
eldest is four and a half and my
youngest is 18 months oh congrats that's
amazing what do you think would you want
to get them into the business one day
like when they leave school and that or
yeah 100% so our actual property um
business is named after them um so
Curtis and Amelia CD
um and that really just goes back to
like what we was talking about
generational wealth so hopefully that
down the road they'll be able to take
the Reigns and have even more success
than we will I I personally think the
best gift you can give your kids and
I've got three kids myself is is your
personal development and passing on the
Baton to them to and educating them I'm
not going to necessarily give my kids
money but what I will give them is I'll
give them knowledge I'll teach them I'll
give them opportunities experiences and
I think that's the best certainly the
best gift you can give your kids so
congrats on what you've done what advice
would you give yourself from a year ago
just before you was made redundant there
you are your job no properties no
property experience what advice would
you give to that person from a year ago
obviously you know you've got to go and
get the knowledge and training um you
can't go in in this stuff blind I just
think you're doomed for fail if you do
so that' be one looking back I would
definitely say a big focus on networking
and building your brand um I just think
like you said earlier if people know who
you are it makes it a lot easier to work
with them and find that they come to you
so that's definitely that's that's
brilliant so Network and knowledge yeah
and again knowledge is so important
because I mean I'm a trainer so
obviously I strongly believe this but
when you try and reinvent the wheel you
might spend six months doing something
which could have taken six minutes if
you just found someone they did it
previously so and if you want to be
anything if you want to be a doctor a
lawyer an electrician you go to unit you
go to college and I think property is
one of the most lucrative professions on
the planet so to get trained properly
makes sense how did you justify the
decision to invol the Academy which is
our sort of topof the mountain
experience you know the mo the most
Platinum thing that we've got how did
you justify that decision so I think
first of all when I was at like working
I I always thought there must be another
way of things other than just doing a
nine to- five Rat Race and kind of
looked into right anybody who's had
success what do they do and regardless
of what industrial sector are in they
always had a percentage of their wealth
in property so that kind of got me down
to the route of seeing you on YouTube
and and stuff like that and I think from
there and then obviously getting the the
first knowledge and understandings um
and then getting my wife involved we
just decided at the time we had recently
purchased our our house um under on
mortgage um under the pretenses that it
needed a new roof so we had a part of a
roof on there and we decided right we
can fix the roof now and we won't be
able to do this or you know we can do
this and not look back and it's
something that yeah so you joined the
academy instead of fixing your roof
yeah I tell you what though I think I'd
rather invest in myself than invest in
my roof abely is is your house standing
still is it okay it's still up and
standing yeah there we go and soon
you'll be able to get have you got your
new roof yet not yet but it's in the
brilliant well listen Craig massive well
done on what you've achieved it's been a
real pleasure getting to know you thanks
for coming on and sharing your story as
well what was it that made you agree to
come on and share your story today um
just to really benefit and help others
um I've seen a lot of success in the
academy some of the guys we've already
mentioned um and just to be able to
share some of that and help out to
anyone that's even thinking about about
property or is a bit concerned or
worried um you know Point them in the
right advice for someone thinking about
coming to the one pound property
Investor's crash course don't think just
come there we go I'll leave a link in
the description come meet me spend a day
with me at the property Investor's crash
course it all starts at the crash course
Link in BIO see you
[Music]
there